you know I've read a number of texts and
stories that have tried to explain the
physiology of Dragons but dragons are
like blimps that's a new one
[Music]
the flight of dragons this one's kind of
exciting for me because this is my very
first patreon sponsored review that is
right if you go to my patreon you do
have the option to actually flat-out
dictate to me
review this here's the first one so this
one I'm pretty sure was brought on by
this particular patron having seen my
review of the rankin/bass The Hobbit
movie which I grew up with and I loved
and I had mentioned in some reply to
comments on that that I actually haven't
seen the flight of dragons which is
basically the only major rankin/bass
release that I haven't seen because I've
seen the last unicorn and Return of the
King and I've even got the the twas the
night before Christmas the one with the
mice that they did IUI grew up on that
too but somehow this one passed me by
so I'm now gonna take a look at this
this one and this one I somehow I
completely missed this was a
direct-to-video release so and at the at
the time that that happened that
actually was kind of a downgrade from
The Hobbit because the Hobbit was made
for TV but honestly at the time made for
TV was a little bit more respected than
direct-to-video was and in some ways the
final results reflects that I'll get to
some of the other stuff in a bit but in
terms of it took me a little while to
queue into the visual quality of it
because it's not bad by any means but I
it didn't take me a minute as far as
getting used to it because my standard
for rankin/bass fantasy is you know The
Hobbit
Return of the King and the Last Unicorn
is the best looking fantasy movie they
ever made and while certainly the
backgrounds of this are incredibly
reminiscent of those other films to the
point that I think they actually might
have reused a few of them from some of
those other move
these the characters are way less
detailed and that in and of itself is
not a problem but zeroed it on that
right away because the level of
character detail was one of the things I
really loved about how they approached
those other films that I mentioned and
in a way that kind of offset the fact
that the fluidity of the animation was
not up to par with something like Disney
or Don Bluth or you know other major
animated releases of the time so for
this to also you know not have as fluted
animation but also not to have the level
of detail I've come to expect and get
used to with rankin/bass fantasy that
that took me a little while I did get
used to it by the end so it's it's not a
fault with the film by any means it was
just something that took me a little
while to sort of get a handle on I think
overall animation quality is probably a
little bit of a halfway meet between The
Hobbit and that was the night before
Christmas it's it's kind of in the
middle both in terms of you know being
more being a mix of the the style from
The Hobbit and the more cartoony design
work and also in terms of the fluidity
of the animation so story wise because I
don't know how many people have actually
seen this one because like you said I
missed it so as far as the story goes we
are dealing with this notion that
dragons and magic our real and exist or
did exist in the world but that whole
side of the world is fading as
technology and science is becoming more
prevalent in the world and in an effort
to basically preserve that you have
these four wizards these four brothers
and they well the green wizard who's our
main one core Elena scorelines they
score lines who is voiced by Harry
Morgan of mass Fame he has the idea to
basically create a magic sanctuary that
where all the magical things will go to
live and they won't be at
risk of continuing to diminish until
they eventually just vanish and die and
these other brothers are on board with
this except for one of them and that
will be Oh Madonn who's the red wizard
he's voiced by James Earl Jones now the
red wizard doesn't want to go along with
this because his particular kind of
magic which is basically dark magic and
rooted in violence and death his is not
getting weaker as science grows more
powerful he's actually getting stronger
and rather than flee he would rather
push humanity in the direction of
developing their science to the point
that they destroy themselves with him we
get glimpses of of nuclear bombs amongst
other things so he doesn't go along with
this plan and they can't enact it if he
if he is fighting them on it so under
the this it's weird and vague under the
guidance of antiquity which is sort of a
god figure ish thing but sort of a vague
sense like destiny is it's weird Cora
Linus he goes forward to the future to
find a hero I'm not fine it's not like
he has to quest to find a network he's
told this guy but it happens to be a guy
from the 20 20th century who is this
kind of poor kind of down-on-his-luck
guy who's obsessed with dragons he's
like he's designed a game and he's
working on a book called flight of
dragons you named Peter Dickinson who
actually wrote the real book flight of
dragons which isn't so much a narrative
as it is a general positing of how
dragons might have been and the movie
takes a story from another that how this
film came together is weird and if you
know that where it's playing as sources
from which I had to look all this up
it's oddly meta in a way but anyway so
they
Quorra lioness takes this guy brings him
back and and with the hope that okay you
are you as someone who is from the world
of technology but also believes and is
fascinated by magic
you can meet this middle ground and you
are the one who can defeat Oh Madonn and
so then you have structurally a fairly
standard quest narrative you know he
gets some people to help them along the
way there's some complications they get
captured they they escape they defeat
the bad guy
the specifics as it goes along are a
little bit odd but I'm gonna come back
to that so I mentioned some of the voice
cast already and they're all pretty good
nobody blew me away though Harry Morgan
has this odd quality to his voice that
no matter what he sounds like his voice
is coming over a slightly scratchy radio
and it's funny I used to think growing
up cuz I I mean I knew he was the mash
but I know him from things like the
Apple Dumpling gang I used to think oh
this is an older show that's just a
scratchy audio not realizing that's just
kind of how the guy's voice sounds so
that that's just sort of an odd thing
that again it's not a problem it's just
something that's weird for me to think
on and and so it's weird hearing just
his voice alone so like is that the
voice cast is all is all pretty good
John Ritter voices Peter who is who is
our hero and he's he's got a good voice
for this sort of oh gee so you know
wonder which which i think is this
movie's strongest aspect it has a good
sense of wonder in this world and and a
good sense of newton Ferraz kind of
restricted the as the animation is
certainly i compared to some of Rankin
basses other projects of similar scope
it does capture that sense of a fantasy
world and a wonderful one and one that's
that you kind of want to see more of you
kind of want to enjoy and and peter is
sharing that with the audience so that
that stuff comes across really well
James Earl Jones is Amba Don he's fine I
mean it's James Earl Jones his voice is
amazing it always is he feels a little
bit wasted because he's kind of only
called upon to grumble and laugh the the
performance that he gives is probably
the best for Holmes that this character
is gonna get but he just more often than
not somebody will say something and his
reaction will just be that's kind of X
that's his go-to response almost
everything as far as the side characters
code they're all good we get we get a
number of dragons in this with a mainly
gore Bosch who is a dragon that it's
something a little bit odd happens with
him I like is that I don't know how
well-known or frequently watched this is
so I don't wanna I don't want to talk
too much in terms of spoilers but
there's kind of an interesting wrinkle
as far as gore bash goes there's
smeargle who's sort of the older you
know wiser dragon who's mainly there to
give exposition about how dragons work
and we do and those are our hero dragons
we do also have a scary you know more
intimidating dragon and we get some
interesting you know scarier dragon
imagery towards the end I say scarier
like it if we were if you were worried
at all about this scaring your kids it
smog from the the rankin/bass version of
The Hobbit is scarier than any of these
dragons even the bad ones so I guess
that's your benchmark
now overall though I came away from this
going I was kind of odd like I said the
quest narrative is is pretty basic
weight and which is fine there's nothing
wrong with that I get the feeling that
this this film was probably more
deliberately aimed at a younger audience
than their other fantasy films or at
least you know very pointedly so because
I I suspect you know The Last Unicorn
The Hobbit returns Kings those were
aimed at kids too but they were also
based off material that was you know
meant for people
they're meant for people of all ages are
meant for you know an older sense of
what a kid was you know James ro Tolkien
may have written Hobbit for in his mind
a six-year-old but his idea of what a
six-year-old could read in our current
idea was what is a good read not the
same thing
so this one really feels much more aimed
at that at that younger group and it
meanders in some odd ways and mainly
there's a lot of divergences just sort
of going into in digging into like
explaining the science behind dragons
and that's where my opening thing with
the blend comic comes from because Peter
after having explained to him how
dragons are able to fly basically breaks
it down on a scientific level and
compares it to a blimp and there's a
number of other things that happen along
those lines in terms of explaining you
know where their fire comes from and and
all these things and it's not
uninteresting but it is kind of
shoehorned in it you do you do sort of
feel how the material from the book
flight of dragons you exploit giving
offering explanations for how dragons
could have existed and the narrative
taken from a story called the dragon and
the George don't don't blend seamlessly
it does often feel like we're gonna put
the story on hold so we can get into the
house of dragon function and initially I
liked it the initially when it had these
little moments of this at first and they
first started coughing I'm like oh
that's kind of interesting but then
there is a middle section where they
basically stopped the story dead in
order to have this protracted
explanation of how Dragons work and
again it's it's neat ideas they're not
they're not exactly seamlessly
integrated though the movie also has a
little bit of an odd structure in that
when there's lots of stuff that is kind
of plot relevant that we don't see
happen instead we get told oh this just
happened now we have a flash back to it
happening I
even right up until the end and that's
odd
that in and it gives the whole thing is
sort of a lack of forward momentum which
doesn't completely make the thing fall
down because in a way that does sort of
feed into the lingering sense of oh
let's just stay here because it is a
cool world but it it's not a lot of
forward push on this thing there's sort
of little bursts of now we're moving
things forward and I was like oh well
let's talk about this and here's what
happened way back when some of the
supporting characters are pretty cool I
actually rather enjoyed there's a night
character who's just who's very you to
step up a limp cup of tea and he's a lot
of fun I enjoy him although he's got a
slightly creepy interest in the princess
melis and who really shouldn't be there
like as a function of the story I mean
in terms of him specifically as part of
his flashback he's like I I promised
myself then that I would fall in love
with her he says this tellen talking
about how he met her when she was five
that's creepy dude even for 82 that's
creepy
but Millis and as a character exists
basically to be a prize at the end it's
not white so blatant as like the quest
is to save her and if you save her
she'll she'll give you kiss it's not
it's not quite it's not quite that level
but it's close she's there strictly to
be a romantic interest but there's
almost no development of that angle so
it's just kind of taken as a given
here's the girl
our hero and her that there got it yeah
like well okay are they gonna spend
maybe a little more time together is is
she gonna travel with them so she gets
to but no no no but they'll end up
together don't you worry about it like I
worried about it I'm a little bit more
concerned why you felt I need to put it
in there but it
it's a basic story and it's a trope and
certainly much more at the time it was
made than now very much a standard and
an accepted troph that your hero gets a
girl at the end so you know if I'm being
fair for the time that it was made it
was Jim's just a standard plot turn I'm
looking at it now and in my case without
nostalgia there's a way more interesting
female character named Danielle
introduced later who also does almost
nothing which is a shame because I kind
of dug her and the last thing I'm going
to talk about is probably counts a
little bit as spoilers again this isn't
this is one of those things that you
would go back and watch to get to get a
sense of just 80s fantasy and sort of
dwell in it for a while not so much for
the plot ends but if you care about the
plot sort of my overall thought is it's
it's fun and if you like this type of
thing if you like of the rankin/bass
fantasies it's definitely worth checking
out I would put it myself at the bottom
of the rankin/bass fantasy films that
I've seen so it's not as good as well as
a unicorn it's not as good as the Hobbit
it's not even as good as a Return of the
King which has some I need to talk about
that what it's so that's a that's an odd
film but but it's still worth seeing
so that bears your thing that you can
take away before I get into the very end
and some spoilers so here we go the way
the villain is defeated is weird
I like the core concepts behind it but I
feel like they weren't properly seated
in order for this to feel like a proper
payoff as opposed to just a really weird
way to defeat a villain so the whole
thing in case you have decided you know
care about spoilers be somewhat seeing
the film already is that Oh Madonn you
know he he goes all out and in one of
the cooler visuals of the of the piece
you know basically sort of his back
emergent and all these dragon Hasley
he's like kinda turns into a Hydra in a
way but not completely cuz his own head
is still like in the chest of this thing
it's a it's an odd look at it
cool and the way Peter defeats him is
basically by saying yeah I don't believe
in you like sitting like seriously said
I deny you here's a bunch of science
facts and Oh Madonn starts to lose power
and vanish and dies which is weird in
and of itself and and feels like it
would have worked better in a narrative
that was a dream like flat-out as
opposed to something that is supposed to
be as real as a fantasy story is
intended to be but in addition to that
doesn't actually make a lot of sense in
terms of what the film has already said
because at the beginning the reason Oh
Madonn is a problem is he's saying that
man's world is making him stronger so
why is the introduction of science and
these concepts weakening and killing him
if it was capable of that why was he
claiming to be getting stronger by man's
darkness it doesn't I feel like the
rules aren't properly laid out and
actually coming back to that guy I
mentioned antiquity and the whole thing
in antiquity I think they tried to pass
it off a bit like the force like it's
the will of antiquity don't question
antiquity like the number of times
antiquity gets said first of all it's
like oh god just stop saying it but
beyond that it feels like oh it feels
like a catch-all excuse a big old hand
wave to just try and explain away
anything that doesn't make sense because
there's a fair amount of stuff that
doesn't make sense
and there's a lot of stuff that's pretty
arbitrary like the fact that Oh buttons
Oh Madonn says yeah well I'm not going
along with this and Cora Linus is all
like well I will defeat him his brothers
go you cannot such as the law the law of
antiquity is like oh how convenient that
this thing we're never gonna get a
proper explanation from is going to make
it so the most logical thing to to do to
deal with this is something we can't do
so let's go on this you know weird
twisty grab the guy from the 20th
century quest thing and that's there's
nothing wrong
it's just it what it comes across as is
lazy writing and just finding a
catch-all to explain all the things that
don't really make sense and again as far
as defeating the villain this way it's
not an awful idea and I actually kind of
enjoy stories where characters
they require belief to be powered
whether it is specifically fear that
powers them or just belief in general I
do find that interesting when it's done
well I feel like it's not a concept that
is properly fleshed out here that just
kind of drop it in as a way for him to
be defeated at the end it's not
completely out of nowhere but as far as
how this world is how this quest
specifically is functioning it feels
like we should have gotten some some
reminders of it because it's basically
brought up as the initial problem people
aren't believing in magic so magics
getting weaker and then only comes back
at the end whereas the whole middle is
just us existing in this fantasy world
where magic works and magics magic is
real so it it felt it it felt like it
needed we needed a reminder or that it
needed to come up and apply again but it
didn't so that was odd to me but again
you had to come back to what I say it
said before if you if you haven't seen
this it is worth seeing it's an art
experience for me because watching this
which is a film I have no specific
nostalgia for I have to wonder if my
experience of this would be similar to
someone watching The Hobbit for the
first time which obviously I have a ton
of nostalgia for and I love and I will
happily defend and I have a feeling it's
probably a lot of people who grew up on
this and are gonna defend some of the
criticisms I've made down in the
comments because they haven't a Salcha
for it because nostalgia is is a very
powerful thing and it does make me think
that sometimes perhaps I let myself get
a little blinded by it what I talk about
things I grew up on but I'm not gonna
stop doing that that's just how it is
but that's the flight of
dragons first-ever patreon sponsored
review in the can hopefully me not
completely loving it doesn't dissuade
people from following suiting and and
I'll get to do more of these in the
future we'll see what happens
and then against the flight of dragons
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it there's all the stuff to do I
mentioned my patreon I got t-shirts
there's Twitter and podcasts that that
act that that I links for everything
down in the description and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]